-People everywhere are still
in quarantine,
and that means
it's harder to see family.
But, luckily, there are still
a bunch of great ways
to stay in touch.
Here to give some tips
about keeping
up with loved ones,
please welcome
"The Tonight Show" Aunts.
Hi, everybody.
-Jimmy!
-Hi, Jamie. Hi, Jamie.
-Oh, I love it.
-Oh, my gosh. This is great.
Why don't you introduce
yourselves
for everyone at home, please?
-Oh, okay, sure.
I'm Aunt Martha.
I'm the nervous one.
-I'm Aunt Joan, the kooky one.
-And I'm drunk.
-Alright, great.
So, I hear you're going to
give us some tips
on how to stay in touch
in quarantine, right?
So why don't we dive in there.
-Okay.
Well, you know,
we're going to get to that,
but, Jimmy,
I've got a lot of questions.
I'm worried.
Are you eating enough?
-What?
-You look thin to me.
You look thin.
-Yeah, do a spin for us.
-Spin.
-Alright, come on, guys.
I'm not doing a spin.
-Let me see your lower half.
I can't...
-Show us your meat.
-I don't want to --
I don't want to -- I don't --
-You've always been
kind of fat-skinny.
It's heart-attacky.
-I'm fine.
'Cause skinny people
can have heart attacks, too.
-Look, I'm eating --
I'm eating fine, Aunt Martha.
Thank you for the concern.
Now, what are some ways families
can stay in touch
over quarantine?
Do you have any thoughts?
-Oh, Jimmy,
aunts always have thoughts.
-For instance, here's a thought.
Why is it you never tell me
when your program is on?
-My program.
Aunt Sue, it's on every night at
the exact same time, my program.
-Why can't I ever get it?
Tonight, I turned on my TV the
same way I always do,
by pressing input six times,
then crying
and calling the fire department.
-Okay.
-And still no "Tonight Show."
She doesn't get
"The Tonight Show,"
and, Jimmy,
I think it's Russians.
-Can we just get -- Can we get
to the tips, please?
People want to know how
to stay in touch
with loved ones, alright?
Let's focus.
-Yes.
Yes. Thank you, Jimmy.
You're so disciplined.
You would have made a great
doctor, but it didn't work out.
Okay. Now, here's a tip.
When you had Scarlett Johansson
on, was she nice?
-That's not -- That wasn't even
close to a tip.
-Oh, you know who you should
have on the show, Jimmy?
My friend Ruth.
She is hilarious.
You know that "Friends" episode
where Ross got the monkey?
-Yeah.
-Ruth's seen that.
-We...
Are we -- are we going to
get to these tips?
We're not going to
get these tips, are we?
-Oh, Joan, Joan,
tell him your skit.
-Oh, yeah, Joan, tell him.
Tell him your skit.
Tell him your skit idea, Joan.
-I'm sure he doesn't
want to hear it.
-Actually, maybe you're right.
Next time,
we'll talk about the skit.
-Okay, so, the other day,
I'm in D'Agostino's,
you know the one
by my apartment,
not the one that
you're thinking of right now,
but that other one.
The cart -- Get this.
The carts were on
the other side of the store.
-What? Sorry. I missed it.
Carts were on
the other side of the store?
-[ Laughing ] The carts were on
the other side of the store.
-Oh. And that's it?
-I mean, you'd obviously
have to add the jokes,
but that's the backbone of it.
-The structure, Jamie.
She's giving you the structure.
-Yeah. You know what?
I was actually really hoping
you guys would come on
and talk about
how to catch up with family,
but, instead, you talked about
everything else.
You talked about my eating
and then the show
and Scarlett Johansson.
It's like I spent all
this time just --
-Catching up with family?
-That's how you do it, Jamie.
-It ain't pretty,
but it ain't fun either.
-You guys are the best.
"The Tonight Show" Aunts,
everybody.
-Jamie, real quick.
Jamie, real quick before you go.
-Yeah.
-Are you pooping?
How are your stools?
-Oh, my goodness. Alright.
Very good.
-Oh, hey, you should have
your cousin Dave on.
He just got into NYU Tisch.
-Okay, I'll work on that.
Okay. Yeah.
-Hello, fire department?
I just pressed HDMI.
-That's it.
We'll be right back with more
"Tonight Show," everybody.
Come on back.
♪♪
Stop worrying about my pooping
and fat-skinny people.